so here's my little tv scope set up on
the patio you've got this lifelong love
of astronomy i imagine you'd had many
telescopes over the years you're going
to set me straight here
i have so no i've never owned a
telescope when i was a kid my dad had a
really nasty little cheap telescope that
we messed around with for a bit
um and i've got an old nautical
telescope that just sort of lies around
the place but i've never owned a serious
look at the sky kind of telescope until
why is that why is that why have you
never had one
um
partly because so the times i've
actually tried to set up telescopes
myself it turns out i'm pretty hopeless
at it you know
if you go to an observatory there's a
nice big telescope which somebody really
competent has set up and controls and
runs for you if it comes to trying to
line up your own telescope and getting
all the bits of kit to work that's not
really something i'm particularly good
at
so
it's never really appealed all that much
until now what is the skill you lack
like what's the thing about you that
made you not good at setting one up
it is this strange thing so years ago
i used to run field trips with
undergraduates out to the canary islands
where there was a telescope that we used
out there which is very basic telescope
and it was very interesting you could
see amongst the students some of them
just had this magic touch that they
could just line the telescope up point
it roughly where they wanted it to be
and there would be the object they
wanted to look at whereas other people
could be you know really technically
competent and try really hard and never
get a decent image out of it and
unfortunately i'm in the latter category
all right it's just like a it's just
like a knack is that like a magic touch
it does it is yeah it really is a bit of
a touch to it um and it's just not
something i'm particularly good at
why has this changed professor did you
take the plunge because of the sort of
the lockdown situation or
no it was a complete coincidence so
actually
a couple of years ago i backed a
kickstarter which is something i'd never
done before um but there was this
kickstarter for basically someone was
saying we're going to produce a
completely idiot-proof telescope and so
i figured that was just the thing for me
so i backed it really early
and then it sort of disappeared for a
while and i didn't actually think all
that much more about it until i got a
notification saying you know your
telescope's being shipped and
conveniently it arrived just as the
lockdown was beginning so right at the
beginning of lockdown i got a nice
telescope to play with so now you've
been doing some lockdown astronomy i
have yeah not exactly from the ideal
site in that it's sort of i can't go any
further than my own back garden at the
moment but i can take the telescope out
there and stick it in the back garden
and point it up at the sky
and start doing some astronomy the only
slight snag i have
here in my back garden is that the
patches of sky i can choose
are somewhat limited
because there are a lot of trees
and my wife won't let me chop them down
i know you've got a lot of trees around
your house and you live in nottingham
which is you know a big city with lots
of light but you can still get the job
done can you
pretty much yeah it is amazing i mean
this whole the whole point of this
telescope is that it's actually designed
to be used in any environment and so
actually what it does is it takes a
whole series of really short exposures
and just keeps adding them up
and some of the test data that they did
was you know in really brightly lit
places where
you really couldn't see much of the sky
at all and the amazing thing is if you
just keep adding the data you know the
light from the stars and the galaxies is
still there and eventually you can dig
it out from the noise of all the city
lights they actually did some tests in
las vegas for example which is not
famous for its lack of lighting
and they were able to see you know deep
deep sky objects from a
parking lot in the middle of las vegas
now you're going to take us through some
of your images that you've imaged from
your backyard in nottingham which i'm
very excited about the obvious first one
to look at is so-called first light can
you explain the term first light for
people who aren't astronomers and what
what that emotes it's it's it's the
magic moment and you know in my case
well actually i had a fair while to wait
for this telescope but it is that magic
moment where you spent years and years
building a telescope or building an
instrument and you finally get to point
it at the sky and see if it actually
works and so the first light image
usually you pick something sort of
reasonably dull and straightforward and
fairly bright just because you don't
want to stress things too much at the
outset and you want to find out what the
problems might be with with your setup
but yeah that first light image when you
first point the telescope at the sky and
take a picture
and hope you get something and in this
case i did
what did what do what did you choose for
first light and why okay so messier 34
very ordinary open cluster about a
little over a thousand light years away
100 million years old so it's not a
particularly exciting object
partly i want to pick it because it
stars and actually one of the things you
want to check with the telescope when
you first set it up is whether it's
focused or not so you want to see how
sharp point like the individual
stars are in it really i picked it
because actually this telescope is
sufficiently smart that if you just say
what's a good object to look at at the
moment it'll tell you
and messier 34 was what the telescope
picked for me
okay and you're happy with the picture
it looks pretty good for a first first
attempt if you ask me
it's pretty good yeah it's a pretty
sharp image it's you know it wasn't
quite in focus i've since figured out
how to better how to focus the telescope
but it's a nice nice picture you know
lots of stars there definitely a cluster
and it proves that it is amazing right
this telescope you just basically you
take it out you plunk it down on the
ground the only thing you have to do is
make sure it's level but beyond that
it basically figures everything out so
it it uses your phone to tell it you
know where you are in the world so it
knows roughly on what the time is so it
knows all that stuff but then you just
point it in some random direction
it takes a picture it figures out from
the pattern of stars as it sees what
direction it was pointed in and at that
point it'll take you anywhere else in
the sky and so part of this was just
testing does that really work and it
turns out it does you say go to messier
34 and you know 10 seconds later there
it is is that taking away some of the
pleasure or the skill for you like
what's what's left to what's your role
now
i i get to pick what i want to look at
as i said it's the you know the stuff
that i'm really not very good at is that
setting telescopes up making sure
everything's aligned with everything
else
finding things in the sky all that stuff
has gone away now and i just get the
pleasure of looking at things in the sky
what have we got next we've got comet
c2019y4 this was just something that was
sort of timely in that it was a comment
that there was an announcement that
there was this comet had come along that
potentially might be quite bright
subsequently it's actually turned out to
be a bit of a bust in that it's fallen
to bits so it's actually fragmented
falling apart there was some hope this
might be one of those bright comments
you can see with the naked eye it's now
not going to be
but there was quite a lot of interest in
it at the time and it's an interesting
target to go after because of course
comets move relative to all the stars
and so you actually have to find its
current coordinates and instead of
telling the telescope to go to a
particular object you actually have to
tell it which coordinates to go to so it
was a good check to make sure that the
telescope could actually pick up things
just on the basis of coordinates and
sure enough there it was when the
telescope swung round to the coordinates
that it had at the time that's not
that's pretty good any idea how far away
that was at the time you imaged it like
are we talking like i don't i don't even
know where to start how close was it
it's coming into the inner solar system
at the moment so it'll be a matter of
you know and a few astronomical units i
would guess i honestly don't know its
orbit was going to take it pretty close
to the sun but i don't think it had come
that far yet so i think it sort of broke
up on its way in
if i can find out where it was on the
night you imaged it i'll put a little
thing on the screen for people at home
in retrospect so they'll get an idea
next on your list here we have uh
m97 which i can i can just make out in
the image
yeah you might need to do a little bit
of work on those images to actually get
things to a point where you can see them
on the video i guess it is pretty faint
um so it's m97 is this thing called the
owl nebula so cool because i think maybe
it was herschel was the first to observe
it and found and drew this sketch of it
which he sketched as a little owl for
some reason but you can see quite why
it's it's this greenish circle with two
dark dots
or two dark holes in it
uh it's a planetary nebula so it's one
of these late stages of a star a bit
like the sun which is in the process of
blowing itself to bits so it's blown off
all its outer layers so the big sort of
round fuzzy thing are the outer layers
of the star that have been blown out
already uh there's a white dwarf star in
the middle you can maybe see the little
bright dot of the white dwarf in the
middle
and then the two dark holes are actually
where the star is now instead of just
blowing everything out symmetrically
it's actually blowing things out along
the poles of the star so it's evacuated
two cavities so those holes are actually
where it sort of tunneled through the
material that it had previously ejected
out so it's quite a lot of structure
going on there
the green coloring blue green coloring
is partly down to scattered light from
the white dwarf which is very hot in the
middle partly down to emission from uh
ionized oxygen it's ionized so it's very
hot and ionized oxygen produces this
sort of characteristic green shade and
then maybe you can see in the very outer
parts it turns red there's a sort of
faint red ring around the outside that's
where it's a bit cooler and you're
seeing that characteristic red emission
which comes from hydrogen gas of course
m97 is also an excellent deep sky video
people can watch absolutely as are quite
a few things we're going to talk about i
think the sun will become a planetary
nebula
this could be how the sun could lack in
five billion years time
m53
and ngc 505.3
yes two for the price of one two
globular clusters actually very close to
each other on the sky and actually both
are very similar distances away they're
two of the more distant ones in the
milky way but they're actually at
similar distances and in similar
direction in fact they're sufficiently
close together they're even interacting
with each other a little bit so there's
some tidal interaction between the two
that's been detected
so they really are sort of twins in that
sense
but the interesting thing about them is
i probably in one or two of my more
careless moments said when you've seen
one globular cluster you've seen them
all
the interesting thing about these two is
they're about as different as you get as
globular clusters go so i mean one of
them is impressively big and bright and
the other is pretty pathetic really
there are five times as many stars in
the brighter one
but actually it looks a lot more
impressive than even that factor of five
because it's very centrally concentrated
so you get this real brightness in the
middle um whereas the second one is it
is a lot fainter but it's also much more
diffuse much more spread out and so it
does show that actually even things
where globular clusters where
everyone sort of thinks they're more all
more or less the same they really can be
very different from each other
you say they're very close on the sky
but you've you've used two different
images to image them they're not so
close they'll appear in one image no i
think they're about a degree or so apart
a couple of degrees apart and the field
of view of the telescope's only about
half a degree so you had to move the
telescope but not really not very far
they really are right next to each other
in the sky just looking at the dates you
image these on the same day as well yeah
yeah so once i'd done one it was no
trouble at all to go to the other one
they're right next to each other and i
think i think the exposure times are the
same as well so it really is kind of a
fair comparison between them next we
have m51 this is a this is a real uh
showboat galaxy this one yeah yeah m51
yeah everyone's favorite galaxy
it's probably it
was one of the early things that i
looked at just because it's such a pushy
galaxy it's glorious spiral structure
the whirlpool galaxy as it's otherwise
known being stirred by its companion
little companion that sort of tidally
stirring things around absolutely
beautiful galaxy to look at and i was
really pleased when i was able to get a
decent picture of it to the naked eye
is it even is anything visible it's not
even a speck is it it's just there's
just nothing to the naked eye i think
it's too faint yeah i think the only
galaxy
largest galaxy a decent distance away
you can see with an atti is the
andromeda galaxy m31
um so this one you really need to
telescope to see that's not a bad image
that one that's starting to get up
around kind of
what i would you know semi-professional
quality
until you compare it to a proper
professional m51 that's the thing i mean
you know i'm really pleased with these
pictures but actually the people who do
this stuff properly and you know do the
so the the telescope i'm using has a
little color detector in it so actually
it's you know you get your whole color
picture all in one go the people who do
the job more properly take pictures
through different colored filters and
then combine them and do use all sorts
of fancy software to really extract the
maximum from their data i'm doing the
easy thing of just having the telescope
bung it all together for me and make a
quick color picture but yeah i'm pretty
chuffed with them it's funny isn't it
even though you've done as little as
almost you could possibly humanly have
done to claim to have made the image you
didn't even align the telescope uh
there's something about knowing it's
your image isn't there it really is it
is bizarre yes and you know all credit
to the technology it did most of the
hard work but i'm still claiming it as
mine
all right m63 we've got another galaxy i
image this one just because it's of a
nice contrast to m51 in that it is
another spiral galaxy it's really rather
a pretty spiral galaxy but completely
different in character in the m51 is one
of these things called a grand design
spiral
n63 uh is what's known as a flocculant
spiral galaxy so called because it looks
sort of woolly it looks like little
tufts of wool it's clearly sort of
completely different in appearance to
m51
and so there's been an interesting point
of contention in astronomy as to what
what it is that causes different types
of spiral structure and it seems likely
that this sort of flocculated spiral
structure probably has a rather
different origin
from the grand design that we saw in
messier 51. i'm just looking have we
done m63 on deep sky videos yes it was
our most recent one yeah and in fact you
put this image in it this image is in
your video yeah
so yes i was just looking i was looking
at the website saying it's not there and
that's because we've done it so recently
i haven't put on the website yet
so in fact part of the part of the
reason i took the picture was because i
knew you were making a video and i
thought i might be able to sneak it into
the video
the sunflower galaxy sunflower galaxy
because it looks like those little fine
petals you find in a sunflower yeah next
ngc
4244 so this isn't in the messier
catalog but it's in the new general
catalog
yeah and you can see it's not as big and
impressive and bright as the things in
the messier catalog which is why it
didn't make it into the messier
catalogue because they really had to be
things that you could find relatively
easily
or rather messier or one of his
collaborators could find relatively
easily but actually part of the reason
why it's not so big and bright is
because it's exactly edge-on it's a
beautiful disc galaxy that we're looking
at sideways on and so it doesn't look as
impressive because you only get that
sort of sideways thin view of it
but at some level it is a very
impressive thing to look at because it
shows quite how thin spiral galaxies
really are how when you do get to see
the mage on they really are disc-like um
so this is a sort of some of the first
evidence that there was as to what the
three-dimensional structure of galaxies
really was the fact that you
occasionally saw them this thin meant
that they had to be really intrinsically
very thin disks of stars next we have
ic342 what's ic i don't know that one so
ic is the index catalog there's the
messier catalogue then there was the new
general catalog came along with a much
bigger catalog of star clusters nebulae
and galaxies
um and then as a sort of supplement to
the new general catalogue the ngc it was
this thing called the ic the index
catalog which essentially sort of
hoovered up a lot of objects that hadn't
been found for the ngc they tend to be
smaller and fainter which is why they
weren't in the ngc and a lot of them
were actually only
found when photography started coming
into astronomy and people could actually
instead of having to observe just with
the eye to an eyepiece could actually
take pictures and see things that have
been too faint to see before
and so this particular galaxy for
example wasn't found until the 1890s
which is surprising because it's
actually it's a big galaxy it's a big
bright galaxy intrinsically it's almost
the same size as the full moon so it
would be a big galaxy on the sky
but it's very very faint and the reason
it's very faint is because it's very
close to the plane of the milky way it's
only about 10 degrees out of the plane
in the milky way
and the milky way contains all this
[ __ ] stuff that absorbs light so that
we're sort of
viewing it through all this obscuration
that's associated with the dust the
[ __ ] material in the plane of the milky
way and so only about a quarter of its
light actually gets through we lose
three quarters of the light from it
which is why it looks so pathetic and
ghost like in those images it's also why
there's so many stars in the images
because we're very close to the plane of
the milky way so we're starting to pick
up more and more of the milky way stars
and so the reason why it ends up looking
so sort of pathetically faint is because
we're viewing it through all this fog of
the interstellar dust within the milky
way which is sort of making it lose most
of the light and so we only see this
sort of race-like appearance of a galaxy
i think i mean my impression my initial
impression which of course you know
after thinking for a few seconds i
realize is ridiculous but because it's
so faint and because there are so many
stars in it it almost creates this
illusion that we're seeing through it
and we're seeing stars on the other side
of it but of course all the stars you
see that are individual stars are well
and truly in the foreground very
definitely yeah yeah and actually part
of the interesting thing is that we're
not really seeing through things at all
right the the reason why things appear
so faint is because we're not seeing
through the milky way and so although we
tend to think of galaxies as transparent
that you can see things behind them this
is telling us that that's not quite the
whole story that actually there is quite
a lot of obscuration in the galaxy which
prevents you from seeing things behind
them we're almost lucky the earth is as
far flung as it is the good news is that
the dust in the milky way is in a pretty
thin plane which means that the number
of directions where we end up looking
through a lot of it is there's not very
many right because most directions you
could look in you're kind of looking out
through it and so you're not looking
through much of it you have to be pretty
unlucky to be looking right in the plane
of the galaxy
so so it doesn't mean there are lots of
directions we can look in but there are
some places where you really can't see
very much just because the observation
is that that intense
mike that obscuring dust that is sits
along the plane of the milky way
how far out does it reach from the
center like are we in it are we sitting
in that dust or does it get more diffuse
out as you get further out into the disk
so it does get more diffused there is
still some there basically wherever
there are stars you end up with dust
because the star the dust comes from
stars some of the late stages of stellar
burning are kind of not they're not
smokeless effectively so they just put
out lots of this [ __ ] material and so
actually wherever there are stars you'll
end up finding dust so stars are big
polluters for all this talk about how
clean solar energy is they really well
most of their lives they're pretty well
behaved but as i say in some of those
later stages where they're sort of
throwing off a lot of their outer layers
of gas and cooling down a lot that's
where you tend to get dust grains
forming so in those late stages you end
up throwing a lot of dust out into the
galaxy okay next we have ngc
yeah i took i mean this is no one's
particular favorite galaxy i took a
picture of it because it's one that i
happen to have written a paper about or
he's been one of the authors on the
paper about this galaxy it's a splotchy
looking galaxy thing called an irregular
galaxy it's a pretty close cousin to the
large magellanic cloud so those from the
southern hemisphere are very familiar
with the large magellanic cloud as one
of the galaxies you can see with the
naked eye is pretty similar to it in
that like the large magellanic cloud it
has a bar-like structure in it it's a
disc galaxy but it's very messy it's not
as tidy as the spiral galaxies it's
quite a bit further away so it's quite a
lot harder to see but the interesting
difference between it and the large
magellanic cloud is it that this galaxy
is producing an awful lot of stars it's
almost a starburst galaxy it's producing
an intense burst of stars right now or
at least in the in the recent past and
one of the unanswered questions until a
couple of years ago was why why is this
galaxy producing stars so vigorously
and what we were able to do by taking a
really deep image so this was an 18-hour
exposure with a half-meter telescope
so still by astronomical standards a
relatively small telescope half-meter
telescope as a smallish telescope but by
looking at this patch of sky for 18
hours we've got a very deep image and
we're able to see that this galaxy
actually has a companion that is ripped
to pieces so it's clearly had a close
encounter with an even smaller galaxy
this is quite a small galaxy to start
with but it's had a close encounter with
an even smaller galaxy and the net
effect of that is it ended up
ripping the other galaxy to pieces but
also triggering a big burst of style
formation in this galaxy
what was it like imaging this one like
for old time's sake and because of a
personal connection and seeing this
splodge like all the other ones but but
having all this extra knowledge about it
and not this like this relationship with
that you form under the fire of writing
a paper about it
so that was really nice but actually the
other interesting thing and the sort of
the warm glow i got from looking at this
one is most of the other galaxies i've
looked at are very sort of they're the
standard galaxies that everyone looks at
right and so actually there are lots and
lots of images of them at some level my
images don't really stack up to the
beautiful ones that some people end up
making and i don't feel like i'm doing
anything you know lots of people have
trodden that path before the nice thing
about this galaxy is not that many
people bother to look at it and so it's
nice to look at a galaxy which is you
know is one of those in one of those
little nooks and crannies that most
people don't bother to explore in
astronomy i feel like you've got off the
beaten track a bit yeah absolutely and
and as you said it's kind of nice to
look at a galaxy where i think you know
i know something interesting about this
galaxy and so you do feel that sort of
connection to it as well yeah
last but not least virgo cluster m87 and
ngc
4550 so yeah so our nearest sort of
brightest cluster of galaxies is one
which i can just about get to through a
gap in the trees so i had to go at
looking at it and it's big enough on the
sky you you don't get to see the whole
cluster at once but you can start
picking out some of the galaxies from it
and so one of the really famous galaxies
in this cluster is messier 87 m87 it's
sort of right near the middle of the
cluster it's a big bright galaxy what
it's most famous for at the moment is
that it's where that image the first
image of a black hole came from remember
the black hole telescope took an image
of it and actually you can just about
see one of the consequences of that
black hole in this image it's quite hard
to pick out
but if you look at about sort of two
o'clock in that image there's a sort of
little bit of an extension in the light
it's not quite round and what you're
picking out there is a hint of the jet
so there's a jet of material being flung
out from that black hole the immediate
vicinity of that black hole and in a
very well collimated way and so m87
famously has this jet it's actually
quite hard to see so i was really
pleased when even with this little four
and a half inch telescope you could
actually start seeing some hints of the
jet coming out of the middle of m87 yeah
it's almost like that's an eyeball and
that's where like the front of the eye
is or something like that it just looks
a little bit distorted doesn't it you
can just see that it's not quite round
there's something going on in that
direction and that really is just a hint
of that jetta material getting flung out
an ngc 4550 is also there you included
that that's another one that i haven't
have a little bit of a personal
connection to it doesn't look like a
particularly exciting galaxy it's one of
these s0 galaxies so it's a disc galaxy
but without much by way of spiral
structure or anything it's pretty much
edge on what it's famous for is that in
the 1990s vera rubin took a look at it
studied the light split the light from
this galaxy up into spectra and found by
studying the doppler shifts in the light
from that spectra that this galaxy is a
bit strange in that it's not rotating
either clockwise or anti-clockwise it's
actually got half the stars going around
one way and half the stars going around
the other way
so it's a real oddity somehow this
galaxy formed with with the stars going
around in this sort of two directions at
the same time and there are lots of
ideas and theories about how it might
have formed and there were some people
were saying well maybe the two discs
form simultaneously and they do look
pretty much identical certainly from the
analysis that vera rubin and her
collaborators did they said that they
look pretty much the same as each other
the bit that we were able to add is that
a few years ago with rather better data
10 15 years later that we could get
we were able to show that actually by
studying the light in great detail the
two sets of stars are not the same
one is quite a bit younger than the
other so actually what happened is one
disc formed rotating one way then the
whole load of gas fell in rotating the
other way and formed another disk of
stars going around the other way
so this uh this period of backyard
astronomy you've been doing uh
do you think it's been good for you like
has it has it has it has it like changed
the way you think in any way as a
professional astronomer or is it just
something you did or like what are you
what are you taking from it i'm enjoying
it fundamentally you know and it's hard
enough at the moment to find things to
enjoy right so it's actually nice to
have something new to try out to play
around with to enjoy doing so i've
enjoyed taking the pictures and thinking
about them a bit and talking about them
and you know i've been putting them out
on twitter and chatting about them so
it's an opportunity for a bit better
outreach in astronomy and it's in you
know you're at some level it is nice to
actually you know instead of just
looking at the pretty pictures that the
hubble space telescope's taken you know
it's nice to look at your own pictures
and then you know they're not as good as
double space telescopes pictures but
that's okay because i made them and it's
just you do get a definite sense of
satisfaction just making the pictures
yourself you're a good salesman mike i
want one of those telescopes now
i bought i bought a manual one
a few years ago and i never saw a single
thing through it because i just couldn't
line it up or get it to work and i just
put it in storage after a few frustrated
nights
that that's why i never bought a
telescope like that i know i would have
done exactly the same thing yeah all
right well thanks for your time
my pleasure i look forward to more
pictures i look forward to taking them
i'll follow you on twitter to make sure
i see them all
mike the sun's can you see your video
picture or not because the sun's coming
to a point where it's half on your face
and half knot you got a towel
sorry a towel um all right
let's see what we can do
yeah it's right here it's too small
oh yeah
if it doesn't fall down on my head
halfway through the recording yeah i
don't think the sun's going to get into
a position which makes it bad again
it's a nice soft light now very well
done
okay so let me just set myself back up
roughly where i was before this is
locked down
uh youtubing people
yeah absolutely